joined by one of the men of the hour
nominated for power of the dog which is
up for eight baftas tonight benedict
cumberbatch nominated for leading actor
i mean it's this brilliant gothic
western for anyone who hasn't caught it
on netflix yet i'm working with jane
campion for the first time in a long
time as well how was that process she's
such a unique filmmaker she's amazing
she really sees you as an actor but also
as a human being and really deeply sees
her characters as her craft proves time
and time again whether it's on the small
screen or the big screen but this has
been the first film place for over a
decade
to be part of that experience with her
and to gain knowledge through the way
she approaches everything through her
process but also the process she
encourages you to go through as an actor
as
for me it really hurts
that you put your heart and soul into it
you went very sort of method with this
as well i did i did on many levels uh i
studied character for the whole shoot
and i was afforded that through her she
introduced me as phil burback and not as
benedict and i'm a little bit apologetic
and
stumbly as myself whereas this guy is
very certain and
as we know uh pretty obnoxious and uh
apparent in some of his behavioral
traits so
yeah i i had to really be given full
permission to do that and go there and
she gave me that just finally for people
at home in case you're thinking that's
lady gaga going past in the background
and what i was just going to say though
while this is a celebration of film
tonight yeah it's a bit of a funny sort
of mood as well obviously people want to
pay respect to what's happening in the
ukraine you've campaigned a lot for
refugees as well absolutely i think you
know this is
[Applause]
we have brothers and sisters who are
suffering
in our industry who are in ukraine or
have managed to escape it whose homes
and families are at risk and
civilians at large who are being shelled
and shot up
and killed are made homeless without
power without water without food it is a
really shocking time
to be the european two and a half hours
flight away from
uh ukraine and it's something that hangs
over us and while tonight is a
celebration and this may look like
tokenism we're celebrating the moving
image we're celebrating pictures so this
is
although i'm saying words now this is
what i'm trying to do to show that i'm
standing side by side with my brothers
and sisters who are going through this
but we all need as we know to do more
than wear a badge
we need to donate we need to pressure
our politicians to continue to
create some kind of a refugee
safety and a haven here for people who
are suffering and figure that system out
i know it's ongoing and that's happening
but
everyone needs to do as much as they can
i think already today the news is break
that there's been a record number of
people volunteering to take people into
their homes and i hope to be part of
that myself and also obviously donating
to charities who can help people in a
very real way on the ground either in
poland or just over the border if it's
safe to do so so
they're extraordinary men and women on
the ground and this is just
acknowledgement of them as much as is
the people they're helping
thank you for talking to us tonight
thank you so much